hello how are you cheers andrés gonzález
with about a training for today
wednesday march 31 governor
steve zizola announced an extension to the
moratorium on evictions in the state it was
supposed to expire today now
the tenants will have them at the end of
may to  ask for financial help and not
be evicted from their homes during
the pandemic, the governor also said
that this will be the last extension
for Nevadans while the
federal moratorium was extended until the end of
June
and if you think you are infected with
Kobe it is important that you do  a
screening test the league stadium does not
offer a kobe window testing event
next week it will be on
wednesday, april 7 from eight in the
morning to one in the afternoon you can make
an appointment on the official website of the
health district or also  you can
visit our page of Indians nou
dotcom diagonal in Spanish
the employees within the properties
belonging to the enter site  tainment
will have the opportunity to receive the
vaccine at work during this week
the company announced that there will be 10,000
doses available distributed in
all properties starting tomorrow the
first center will take place inside the
river hotel and casino for a more
detailed list visit our page on  line
now let's see the temperatures that
await us for the next few days we will have
a sunny and hot day reaching
74 degrees however the temperatures
go up to 90 for the weekend
remember to stay hydrated I wish you
a happy Wednesday I am andrés
gonzález and this was  his previous
informative of news now in Spanish
[Music]